[Musique]
samedi 17 décembre blog numéro 3 mais il
doit être quelque chose comme 15 heures
c'est l'heure du repas magnifique bar
était préparé les cannois et de
décrocher un petit peu les plans de
regarder ce que gérer ce qui est bien et
ce qui va pouvoir servir pour demain
pour la vidéo de ce soir que vous vous
aurez de même bien évidemment je crois
qu'il va falloir investir
je suppose que vous le savez mais c'est
bientôt noël
parce que franchement ça va être un
super doit aimer ça on en reparlera un
petit peu plus tard aujourd'hui on va
parler d'autre chose on va lui faire un
petit tour en ville pour aller voir ce
qui se trame voir ce qu'on peut trouver
de sympa en idées de cadeaux de noël
parce que mine de rien c'est dans une
semaine le réveillon donc il faut
franchement avancé à plein plein plein
plein de choses à faire
je me suis un petit peu isolé dans ma
cabane en bois tout le monde dort là où
il y en a une qui est sorti hier soir
qui s'est couché quand même relativement
tard et qu'il a fait la sieste
je voulais vous remercier pour vos
premières réactions concernant les deux
premiers vlog qui sont parues hier et
avant-hier les retours sont plutôt
sympas concernant la vidéo d'hier où je
pousse un petit coup de gueule contre un
peuple et tout son matériel que j'adore
ceci étant dit il est tout de suite chez
en train de filmer avec avec mon iphone
parce que la caméra principale l'osmose
est en charge
on a par une prochaine fois d'ailleurs
c'est la grande maladie de cette machine
qui est fantastique c'est la durée de
vie de la batterie franchement c'est
naze complètement reste par contre je
confirme ce que j'ai dit hier j'ai
terminé à plus de 5 heures du matin la
vidéo je suis complètement éclaté pour
l'instant on va aller faire un petit
tour et on va aller voir ce qui se passe
du côté des cadeaux de noël 90
[Musique]
c'est pas mal du tout ce truc ans j'en
ai plein alors je profite citron c'est
pas mal aussi
il est 23h45 la journée quasiment
terminé
j'ai quasiment fini le montage de la
journée mais je suis quasiment prêt à
tout envoyer sur youtube sauf que je me
suis rendu compte que les choses que
j'osais pas montré aujourd'hui forcément
heureusement pas tous forcément j'ai une
vie privée et ce qui est privé même si
je vous aime beaucoup restent privés
forcément principes de la vie privée ce
que vous voyez pas c'est qu'après cette
jolie balade
nous avons fait un petit apéro fort
sympathique à la maison pour sa tasse on
vous vous en foutez il ya pas grand
chose à voir mais je vous réserve des
choses relativement sympa demain demain
y aura du sport et une seule chose si
vous aimez bien
abonnez vous
[Musique]